Саме в цьому будинку журналіста Яна Куціака
і його дівчину Мартіну Куснірову знайшли
застреленими. Сусіди досі не можуть оговтатись
від того, що наприкінці лютого в їхньому тихому селі
трапилося холоднокровне вбивсто в стилі мафії.
Серед багатьох приїжджих - представники
Європейського парламенту.
Це дійсно саме той момент, коли усвідомлюєшь,
що сталося. Ми повинні працювати над створенням світу,
де такі речі просто не зможуть трапитися...
Це не можна залишити безкарним.
Але чи є у влади політична воля, що знайти
вбивць журналіста, який розслідував корупцію
серед можновладців?
Делегація з Європарламенту запитала про це
прем'єр-міністра Роберта Фіцо, але його відповідь,
вочевидь, їх не переконала.
Лунає так багато звинувачень у корупції, шахрайстві
та злочинній діяльності. Дуже багато диму,
тож за цим явно є вогонь.
Ти просто не знаєш точно, де саме. Багато людей
дуже нервують, і країна явно розколота.
"Ганьба!", - кричать протестувальники, які вийшли
на вулиці Братислави. На вихідних відбулася
найбільша демонстрація в історії країни.
Мітингувальники вимагали відставки Фіцо.
У нашому уряді багато злочинців.
Ми не хочемо більше цього терпіти.
Ми повинні змінити все це, цю корумповану систему.
Настав час. Вони перетнули межу.
У ньюзрумі видання Aktuality.sk, де працював
Ян Куціак, багато журналістів все ще налякані та
не бажають, щоб їх знімали. Мартін Турек,
друг убитого, також нервує, але на інтерв'ю
погоджується.
Ми аж ніяк не очікували, що щось подібне
трапиться у 2018 році в державі-члені ЄС...
Коли стається щось на кшталт такого, це повністю
змінює те, що ви думаєте про свою роботу,
про журналістику в Словаччині
і майже про все інше…
Поки делегація з Брюсселя збирає факти
про історію вбивства, з'являються нові докази
про корупційні зв'язки уряду та членів мафії.
Країна опинилася в найглибшій політичній кризі
за останні 25 років. Президент Андрей Кіска
закликав до відповіді прем'єр-міністра
та його союзників.
Мені приємно, що коли котрась з країн-членів
Євросоюзу стикається з проблемою, інші держави
ЄС готові надати допомогу. Я сподіваюся, що ми
отримаємо чітку та відкриту відповідь
на всі запитання.
Президент наполягає на формуванні нового
кабінету міністрів або проведенні перевиборів.
У відставки вже пішли міністр внутрішніх справ,
міністр культури та низка урядовців нижчого рангу.
Проте цього замало: від уряду в Братиславі
вимагають повної ротації.